so you might have encountered logarithms  in your mathematic examinations but have  you ever stopped in thought what are the  real life use cases of logarithms there  are plenty let me tell you okay so  logarithms are used to create  measurement skills that are more  manageable right let me give you a few  examples for instance the Richter scale  to measure earthquakes right the decibel  scale to measure sound even the pH level  of chemicals we also use logarithms to  measure exponential population growth  now these are just a very few examples  if there are more examples that you can  think of comment down below okay now  don't forget to like this video  subscribe to our Channel and hit the  Bell icon so that you don't miss out on  any future uploads